naïm chili bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation à la matinale de rtl france
alors est ce que les mots de la ministre
frédéric vidal sont de nature à vous
rassurer aujourd'hui
pas tellement pas tellement déjà on
tient à souligner le fait il ya un gros
problème le fait que ces annonces par
rapport à l'entrée ont lieu moins d'une
semaine avant la rentrée effective ce
qui laisse présager du fait que les
jeunes y resteront pas trop le temps là
divinisé pour la mettre en place de plus
l'annoncé dans la presse dans un article
qui a exceptionnellement pour les
abonnés c'est une certaine forme de
communication envers les étudiants mais
au delà de la forme nous ce qu'on
dénonce c'est un peu le désordre
permanent la ministre a dit il y aura
protocole sanitaire vous inquiétez pas
tout va bien se passer et quand on
regarde le protocole ne dit pas de jauge
dans les salles et bat distanciation
physique ce qui laisse présager que on
n'a pas forcément la bonne stratégie
pour empêcher un retour de l'épidémie
notamment on a dit la ministre à les
voir à la rentrée simplement quand ça se
passe allez voir c'est end en fille
bondée où des étudiants s'entassent ou
dans certains cas ils sont même assis
sur les marches d'escalier et qui
viennent nous dire que dans ce cas là
ben oui ce protocole il permet de
débiter un retour de l'épidémie pareil l
annonce par contre le port du masque
obligatoire mais refuse d'en fournir
gratuitement aux étudiants alors qu'on
sait qu'aujourd'hui la gestion qui
effectivement ben préfère se nourrir
plutôt que acheter de nouveaux masques
et donc vont porter pendant plusieurs
heures plusieurs jours le même masque
donc si le désordre permanent il n'y a
pas de cadrage chaque établissement fait
ce qu'il veut donc si on ne sait pas
vraiment de nature à nous rassurer pour
cette rentrée est ce que vous auriez
préféré la mise en place d'une jauge
finalement même si
les étudiants ont beaucoup souffert de
la solitude et travailler tout seul chez
eux à distance
nous on aurait voulu évidement nous en
place d'une jauge pour garantir de
bonnes conditions sanitaires éviter
voilà il ya un retour de del épidémie
nos établissements sauf que ça veut pas
dire qu'une partition vallée du reste et
en distance yale c'est qu'on aurait très
bien qu avoir des jauges messieurs
seulement faire des demi groupe
répartira les situant différemment de
rétablissement mais cela serait supposé
qu'on investisse en terme de place en
terme de moyens en terme de locaux
d'enseignement d'enseignants pardon donc
ça c'est des choses qui étaient
possibles dès l été dernier on a fait
différentes projections qui montrait que
l'on pouvait assurer une rentrée en 100%
résidentiel en présentiel pardon est
hachurée aussi le respect de la
distanciation physique si c'est pas le
cas c'est parce qu'on a un gouvernement
qui a refusé d'investir dans son
supérieur ça fait déjà quelques années
et a posé un problème vis à vis de nos
conditions d'études là ça pose un
problème aussi vous avez une condition
sanitaire peut-être 20 % des étudiants
qui vont être vaccinés à la rentrée
selon le le les annonces du gouvernement
pas de difficulté particulière
aujourd'hui pour pour les étudiants à la
fois pour avoir accès à la vaccination
ou même pas de réticence particulière
non comme vous l'a dit on voit qu'il ya
au delà des idées reçues une très large
majorité 80% doublé 10 des étudiants
étudiantes qui seront vaccinées à la
rentrée ce qui montre que voilà au delà
des stéréotypes qu'on fait sur la
jeunesse il ya aussi la réalité la ssii
on continue à dire qu'il faut quand même
garantir l'accès à la vaccination la
ministre avait annoncé que sur chacune
et d'études il y aurait un centre de
vaccination à la rentrée qui serait
ouvert déjà dans son interview est le
modifier un peu cela elle dit que pour
certains petits sites isolés cela ne
sera pas tout le temps le cas dans
certains ce sera qu'une seule fois une
seule à ce jour par semaine donc on voit
que là encore entre les annonces et les
choses concrètes il ya une
différenciation nous on pense que voilà
la vaccination est une bonne solution
pour mettre fin à ce tv ni que c'est de
bonne augure c'est de mise en place de
centres vaccination mais par contre il
faut qu'elle soit effective sur tout le
territoire et que les petits sites ne
soit pas abandonnée au profit des gros
campus alors les bacheliers qui ont deux
l'année dernière qui vont entrer cette
année à la fac finalement ont eu une
année difficile deux dernières années a
c'est assez compliqué est ce que comment
est ce qu'ils vont être reçus est ce
qu'il y aura un accompagnement
particulier pour eux
bah pas de pad accompagne en particulier
d'après les annonces de la ministre
bastien souligné que notamment les avis
de la vie étudiante alors que ça fait 2
1 ou 2 ans que des étudiants vivent
totalement dit en ciel non pas en cours
est dans des chambres course extrêmement
petit est bien la seule annonce
concernant la vie étudiante c'est la
mise en place du pass sanitaires à
l'entrée des événements festifs alors il
ya tout un tas de choses à faire pour
réfléchir à comment on peut recréer la
socialisation sur les campus l comment
faire pour accueillir effectivement les
suivantes qui arrive en 1ère année la
seule mesure de la ministre c'est une
mesure sécuritaire et notamment on le
sait en cours d'autant plus scandaleux
quand chaque année les étudiants payent
la cec la construction de 80 de campus
qui le taxent étudiants pouvoir
s'inscrire dans l'enseignement supérieur
sont embêtés jusqu'aux grandes écoles
c'est 92 euros et qui sont censés
financer la d'étudiantes soit comme on
le sait ces deux années cet argent il
n'a servi à rien puisqu'il n'avait pas
de l'étudiante et donc sur trois ans et
276 euros questions ont déboursé
simplement pour rien et alors qu'on y
avait des choses à faire chacun relève
étudiante et nous on a encore tout à
fait disposées à participer à des
discussions pour réfléchir comment le
mettre en place d'événements et qui
respecte les règles les gestes barrière
qui permettent souvent d'éviter un
retour épidémie genre de choses mais qui
ne tombe pas non plus du tout
sécuritaire eh bien on voit que la
ministre elle n'a pas d'autres
réflexions que passer une terre tout
rien et qu'importe la socialisation des
premières années leur accompagnement
merci beaucoup même chili d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl franc je le rappelle vous êtes
secrétaire national d'alternative
étudiants